en el vídeo anterior hablamos la
interfaz en la cual es la parte con
mayor duración en el ciclo de la vida de
una célula y en la interfase la célula
crece va creciendo su adn se replica y
después sigue creciendo ahora vamos a
hablar de la división celular vamos a
hablar de la mitosis y si queremos ser
precisos la mitosis es el proceso por el
cual este único núcleo que tenemos aquí
se convertirá en dos núcleos donde cada
uno de ellos tendrá la información
genética original ahora cuando la célula
sale de la mitosis empezarán las
citocinas ys la cual va a separar estos
dos núcleos y los pondrán en células
separadas ya que se para escrito plasma
divide a la célula y con esto se
formarán dos células pero ahora veamos
cómo sucede todo eso y para esto vamos a
bajar un poco la pantalla me voy a
quedar con esta última fase que
estábamos viendo en el vídeo anterior y
vamos a hablar de la mitosis bien
entonces en la primera fase y para eso
voy a poner otra
para camps en la primera fase lo que
vamos a ver es lo siguiente y recuerda
que en el final de la interfaz de justo
aquí tenemos una célula grande y el adn
ya se replicó tenemos dos centrosomas
justo aquí y entonces en nuestra primera
parte de la mitosis voy a dibujar una
célula pero un poco más pequeña para
tener suficiente espacio para explicarte
todo acerca de la mitosis voy a decir
que es esta misma célula estoy dibujando
un poco más pequeña para que nos quepa
toda la explicación y en esta fase pasa
lo siguiente en primer lugar el adn los
cromosomas que tenemos aquí van a pasar
de la forma cromatina donde estaban
completamente extendidos y desarrollados
y estos van a pasar a una forma un poco
más condensada se van a enrollar y de
hecho se pueden ver desde un microscopio
óptico entonces por ejemplo este
cromosoma que tengo aquí de color
magenta que recuerda que estaba formado
por estas dos cromáticas hermanas que
tenemos aquí recuerda que justo aquí lo
explicamos teníamos dos cromáticas
hermanas
este es un cromosoma y este también es
un cromosoma formado
por 2 pro mate a las hermanas bueno pues
este ahora que regresamos justo por acá
este cromosoma de color magenta se va a
ver más o menos así en su forma con
lanzada si lo visualizará en un
microscopio se vería más o menos así
esta sería una de las cromáticas
hermanas y por aquí tengo otra de ellas
la voy a poner más o menos así algo así
es muy poco probable que sea magenta
pero bueno tendrá esta forma clásica de
los cromosomas que estás acostumbrado a
ver en los libros de texto y bueno
también tiene un centro mero recuerda no
lo olvides está justo aquí nuestro
centro mero y bueno recuerda que éstas
se consideran un solo cromosoma incluso
antes de la replicación esta cosa
magenta ya se consideraba un solo
cromosoma y ahora también podemos
dibujar el cromosoma de color azul lo
voy a poner con este color se va a ver
más o menos así voy a tener aquí a mi
cromosoma de color azul lo voy a poner
más o menos así y por acá voy a poner a
su cromática hermanas éstas
esta es la otra de ellas voy a poner más
o menos así y bueno también voy a poner
su centro mero su centro pero se va a
ver más o menos así y entonces conforme
entran a la mitosis éstos están
condensando y la membrana nuclear que
tenemos aquí está empieza a desaparecer
así que la voy a poner así porque justo
está empezando a desaparecer se ve más o
menos así y ahora estos dos centros o
más que tengo aquí esos dos van a migrar
a lados opuestos de la célula uno se va
a ir más o menos hacia este lado se va a
ir más o menos hacia este lado mientras
que el otro se va a ir hacia el otro
extremo hacia el lado opuesto se va a ir
para acá y realmente quiero que pienses
que esto es increíble sabes es que es
muy fácil decir bueno esto pasa después
esto pasa después esto pasa pero
recuerda esta célula no tiene cerebro
todo esto sucede debido a reacciones
químicas y termodinámicas con base bueno
a ciertos activadores
los cuales ocurren según el momento en
el que se encuentra la célula y su ciclo
de vida y bueno aunque esto pasa es
increíble que esto suceda es increíble
que estas estructuras que a veces
consideramos que son cosas muy simples
de hecho son cosas increíblemente
complejas es bastante sorprendente como
de cierta manera saben qué hacer y esto
a pesar de que no hay inteligencia aquí
y mucho de lo que estoy hablando aunque
el proceso general está bien ha
entendido los científicos continúan
estudiando cómo exactamente suceden
todas estas cosas cuando deben de
suceder que el mecanismo suceden y bueno
también se preguntan qué sucede
exactamente con las bases moleculares y
atómicas pero bueno de cualquier manera
esta fase de la mitosis donde la
envoltura nuclear es decir esta membrana
nuclear empieza a desaparecer los
centrosomas migran al lados opuestos y
el adn se condensa de hecho está en su
forma más condensada de los cromosomas a
esta fase se le llama pro fase pro fase
de la mitosis
así que déjenme anotarlo esta se llama
la pro fase
ahora en la siguiente fase va a pasar lo
siguiente y para eso lo primero que voy
a hacer es dibujar mi membrana celular
la voy a dibujar más o menos así para
que veas lo que pasa en esta siguiente
fase lo primero que va a ocurrir es que
esta membrana nuclear ya desapareció y
ahora los cromosomas estos dos comienzan
a alinearse a la mitad de la célula
entonces déjame ponerlos por aquí voy a
poner por aquí al primero de ellos voy a
ponerlo justo así más o menos se ve algo
así o bien algo así me gusta y bueno
también voy a poner al de color azul que
se va a ver más o menos así y bueno
recuerda realmente no creo que se vea de
color azul o de color magenta pero estos
colores se ven padres y por eso me gusta
que ponerlos así me gusta ponerlos de
estos colores bien se están alineando
justo a la mitad de la célula y bueno
ahora que ya tenemos estos dos de aquí
vamos a conectarlos con el centro -
recuerda estas son dos
las hermanas aquí está su centro mero y
aquí está el otro y recuerda no
confundirlos con los centrosomas que de
hecho ahora los voy a utilizar porque
los centrosomas están en extremos
opuestos de la célula por aquí voy a
tener a uno de ellos y hasta acá voy a
tener a otro de ellos en extremos
opuestos completamente y es más déjenme
anotar aunque estos son los centrosomas
es importante que no te confundas con
los centro meros centro tomás o key y
bueno también voy a escribir que estos
son los centros los recuerdas este de
aquí es un c
pero bueno para seguir con las palabras
de centro y algo ahora a lo mejor has
oído la palabra de central o y de hecho
los centros se encuentran adentro de los
centrosomas y son dos son dos cosas con
formas de cilindro que voy a poner más o
menos por aquí 12 por aquí también voy a
poner 12 y bueno los estoy mencionando
para que veas que también hay más
palabras con esta raíz en común estos de
aquí son c en trío 2
3 o 2 y seguimos con la idea de las
palabras con centro pero bueno para los
fines de este vídeo lo que quiero
decirte es que los centros son parte de
los centrosomas espero que esto te ayude
a generar menos confusión en todos estos
términos pero bueno lo que quiero
decirte aquí es que estos de aquí estos
dos cromosomas se alinean a la mitad de
la célula y lo que va a pasar es lo
siguiente toda esta organización de
estas cosas moviéndose en la célula
cosas alineándose y de pronto alejándose
todas estas están coordinadas y están
coordinadas por mecanismos bastante
sofisticados por los andamios y unas
ciertas cuerdas que voy a llamar
microtúbulos los microtúbulos son esos
que voy a poner aquí que van a unir al
cromosoma con el centrosoma al cromosoma
con el centrosoma pero también van a
unir a los dos centros o más así que lo
voy a poner más o menos así son todos
estos que conectan a estos dos centros o
más voy a poner
otro por aquí más o menos así y bueno
también va a estar conectado esté con
nuestros centrosomas así que voy a
conectar a estos dos el papel de estos
de estos microtúbulos es muy importante
porque ellos van a ayudar a empujar esta
célula hacia los dos extremos van a
ayudar a estos centros o más en gran
medida a empujar y jalar las cosas todas
hacia el lado correcto estos ayudan a
que estos dos centros o más este y éste
se alejen entre sí y como veremos en la
siguiente fase son capaces de separar a
una cromática hermana de la otra
entonces esto de aquí donde la membrana
nuclear ya desapareció y los centrosomas
están extremos opuestos y bueno los
cromosomas están alineados justo así se
llama la meta fase la meta fase de la
mitosis así que la voy a poner aquí la
me
fase porque vayamos a nuestra siguiente
fase pero ya estoy seguro que puedes
imaginarte que viene después en la
siguiente fase y voy a intentar hacerlo
un poco más pequeño para que me quepa
todo en esta pantalla que tengo aquí en
la siguiente fase va a pasar lo
siguiente se va a ver más o menos así
déjame dibujar ahora a mi celular se va
a ver más o menos así algo parecido a
esto esta es mi membrana celular la voy
a poner algo así y bueno aquí tengo a
mis dos centrosomas
voy a poner uno por aquí y otro por acá
y ahora todos estos microtúbulos que
teníamos van a unir también a estos dos
a los dos centros o más pero ahora van a
fungir un papel muy importante porque
ahora van a separar completamente a
estos cromosomas se va a ver más o menos
así dejar poner esto por acá y ahora lo
que va a pasar es lo siguiente cada una
de esas cromáticas hermanas se van a
separar y eso va a pasar porque este
centrosoma baja la hace a un lado y este
otro centrosomas va a jalar hacia
y déjame dibujar esto entonces esta es
una cromática y la va a estar jalando
más o menos para acá se va a ver más o
menos así esta es una de las prometidas
muy bien y entonces esta es la otra de
las cromáticas hermanas ahora está
siendo calada hacia el lado contrario y
va a pasar lo mismo con este de color
azul tengo a una de ellas que va a ser
calada para acá se va a jalar más o
menos por acá algo más o menos así y va
a pasar lo correspondiente con esta otra
y ahora sí si estás muy preocupado por
las palabras que involucran en este
vocabulario entonces en este punto te
puedo decir que cada una de estas
cromáticas hermanas se ha separado y por
lo tanto cada uno de estos cuatro es ya
un cromosoma independiente aquí tenemos
las cromáticas hermanas pero cada una de
ellas se separó lo que da origen a
cuatro cromosomas independientes éstas
van a ser caladas cada una para este
lado
para este lado y este para este lado y
este para este lado y en este punto de
aquí llamamos a estos y neto coro pero
lo impresionante de todo esto es que
saber exactamente cómo funcionan y cómo
se mueven las cosas no está
completamente comprendido algunas de
estas cosas están comprendidas pero
otras siguen siendo un tema de
investigación es impresionante que algo
tan básico como la división celular al
final de cuentas no es tan básico
entonces esta fase en donde empiezas a
ver que el adn se separa y todo está
migrando a sus respectivos lugares de la
célula a esta fase la llamamos la una
fase la una fase
fase de la mitosis y esta última fase se
le conoce con el nombre de la
te lo pasé de él
vamos a hablar de la tela base para la
mitosis y bueno ya empezaba yo a dibujar
por aquí lo que más sucede delante de la
fase estos pequeños pellizcos que le
estamos dando a la membrana celular ya
que iba a ser más acentuado así que
déjame intentar dibujarlo más o menos
así voy a dibujar por aquí y en una de
esta parte de la célula algo más o menos
así y bueno voy a poner la otra más o
menos así algo así y bueno en la tela
fase se va a ver lo siguiente la célula
se va a preparar para lacito sinesis una
preparación para que la célula se separe
en dos ya que la citó cine si se
considera un proceso separado de la
mitosis pero para obviamente estos dos
procesos actúan juntos para que la
célula se pueda dividir y formar dos
células y entonces voy a empezar con mis
centrosomas voy a poner uno por aquí y
voy a poner a otro por acá y ahora voy a
agarrar cada una de estas cromáticas
hermanas que bueno ahora no son
cromáticas hermanas ya se separaron y
cada una
es un cromosoma independiente así que
voy a agarrar el primero y lo voy a
dibujar por acá más o menos así y bueno
puede agarrar voy a utilizar este mismo
color para dibujar a este otro en bueno
en el otro lado y bueno ahora voy a
agarrar al otro al de color azul y lo
voy a dibujar también por aquí lo voy a
dibujar también por aquí algo más o
menos así y bueno por acá tengo al otro
lo voy a dibujar más o menos así y de
hecho de hecho esperan voy a quitar
todos estos cuatro porque lo que quiero
que veas es que la tela fase se dice que
es el proceso inverso a la profa se y
entonces voy a dibujar un poco distinto
en la profa se teníamos que la membrana
celular empieza a desaparecer y los
cromosomas recuerda que se empezaban a
condensar y en la tela fase va a suceder
justo lo contrario por lo tanto deja de
dibujar primero los cromosomas este
cromosoma se va a ver más o menos así
está un poco condensado pero ya empieza
a desarrollarse esto también está un
poco condensado pero bueno también
empieza a desarrollarse y pasa lo mismo
con este azul
aquí lo voy a dibujar algo así pero
también empieza a desarrollarse y bueno
lo voy a dibujar así y también ya está
empezando a desenrollar esté más o menos
así y bueno si en la profa se el núcleo
celular empezará a desaparecer
aquí la membrana nuclear empieza a
formarse de nuevo así que la voy a poner
más o menos así aquí se va a empezar a
formar la membrana nuclear y bueno por
aquí también va a pasar lo mismo se
empieza a formar esta membrana nuclear
entonces al final de todo esto
esencialmente tendrás que ya se formaron
estas membranas nucleares esta de aquí
también ya se formó y bueno este adn
volverá a su forma de cromatina y luego
sucederá a la citó cine sis y las citó
cine sis en general es el proceso por el
cual esto que tenemos aquí que está un
poco pellizcado esto que tenemos aquí se
va a separar iba a formar dos células
completamente separadas se va a ver más
o menos así esto aquí va a ser la citó
cines is algunas personas dirán que esto
inicia en la fase otros van a decir que
terminan la t la fase pero sucede cerca
del final de la mitosis
entonces esto de aquí es lacito cine sí
sí sí sí
sí sí y bueno esencialmente esta célula
grande que tiene ahora dos núcleos se va
a separar en dos células completamente
distintas y van a regresar a este punto
al punto inicial de la interfase a este
punto de aquí y bueno ya que tengas
estas dos células si regresamos para acá
abajo lo que va a pasar es que cada una
de ellas va a regresar a cada una de las
fases del ciclo celular es decir
comenzarán por g1 y luego seguirán por
la fase e se van a replicar su adn y
luego pasarán a la fase 2 donde crecerán
un poco más y luego van a comenzar la
mitosis de nuevo estas dos células se
convertirán en cuatro células en fin
ojalá hayas disfrutado todo este vídeo